Hi guys! My name’s Michael.
And today’s “I Gotta Question” is...
"How can I make the transition from
using my media skills for the world
and using them for God?"
At first, I want to share you guys a verse.
Well, speaking of my experience, I used to love movies and games.
I’m so into media and just self taught myself many related skills.
When Covid hit, people spend more and more time online due to the restriction.
Media becomes more and more important.
And during that time, I just graduated and just desperately needed a job.
You know how hard it is to find a job during that time.
I tried a lot of places, submitted hundreds of resumes
but none of them went through.
To be honest, at that time, I thought I will never get a media related job that I want.
I just can't. It's just too tough.
I started to pray and my church family is also praying for me too.
And during that time, my church is needing someone to edit videos.
I have a lot of free time, so I offered my help.
Then I started to taking over many media related work at my church.
I edit videos, design logos, brochures, create websites.
I stopped being so anxious about job searching.
I leave everything to God and I know God will provide.
I just fully concentrate my skills to help my church.
I’m thinking, you know, if I’m going to create media, why not create something good?
I have the skills and I want to help others.
Out of one hundred projects that I created, if there is only one video,
only few people watched it and made a difference in one person's life,
Then I think it's worth it.
One day, one of my church members just approached me and introduced me to Little Light Studios.
That's how I get to know this ministry and looking back from now, I think this is just God's plan for me.
I waited at the right time, put the trust in Him and He just gave me the perfect job for me.
I can work at a ministry which serves God, help others and I’m doing media works, doing the things that I like.
It's just like your dream job becomes true.
I get paid to do the things I like to do. How amazing that is!
So let’s get back to the question.
How can you make the transition?
First of all I think, don't give up.
Please, please never give up on the talent that God gifted to you.
There are times you may find it frustrated,
you think it's useless or you may think others can do better than you.
But every human being is unique and the talent that God gifted to you is unique.
So just keep doing what you wanted to do.
But do be careful about the direction you choose though.
God gives us the freedom to make choices.
It's either God's side or Satan's side.
Media is a powerful tool, but be sure to use it right.
That little piece of information you put it out may make a huge impact on someone's life.
So it's very important to identify which side are you on.
So my second suggestion is that, start to make something good even if it's tiny.
You don't have to make those big Bible, teach lessons or straight-forward, preaching videos.
You don't have to paint pictures of Jesus thousands times and put it all over the street.
You can just simply by just doing little things, things that can help others, spread the love.
Things that satan just never want you to do.
You can catch the beautiful creations that God made, look at the mountains, rivers, trees around you.
Share them to others. You can write blogs, posts to encourage those who are in struggle, even just a single, warm comment would make a big difference to someone else.
Video record the moments that God's working in your life, that people are spreading love, that people are doing good to others, helping others.
Promote love.
Share God's words.
The point that I want to make is that using your media skills for the world and using it for God doesn't conflict with each other.
I think, you know, God created the world, the world belongs to God.
As long as you are doing what the Bible says, you stand on God's side.
Put yourself in God's hands and let Him lead the way. Spread His message and love.
You are already doing something for God.
You don't need to be in a church or a ministry to do God's work.
You can do anything, anywhere, anytime to share God's message.
And they don't need to be big or perfect.
So, let’s start today.
Pick up your camera, your phone, your computer, your brushes.
Just start to use your talent that God gifted to you.
And you can become another Little Light Studios.
At the end, let me share you guys another verse.
Thank you guys for watching.
Please make sure, you know, put a thumbs up and subscribe to us.
And you can leave your questions to the comments or directly send the questions to us.
And...
And you can guess what I’m going to say.
Kendi: “And bye, bye!”
And bye, bye.
再见